today they're um they're aiming at
civilian people
they're destroying our city our city is
over one million people and
they are they have been warming since
morning since morning and only
only
districts where civilian people live
where there are no military forces
nothing just block of floods
supermarkets
and some
some small shops now i am in the
bathroom the whole family is in the
staircase because the basement of the
block of floods
is not a good shelter
a lot of people went to their metro
station
and
but it is far from our block we will not
have enough time to run there i am
staying at my sister with her
parents-in-law there are eight of us
and
i have
a
young nephew he's just eight
years old he's afraid we have been
bombed every day but today we this is
something special they are bombing
civilians
we have a lot of people um a lot of
people who died in the streets
um a lot of people who are uh who are
hurt
so we can't we do not have enough
shelters because ukraine is a peaceful
country and we were not prepared for war
so it's very tiring
um i can't be scared i can't show my
so that i'm afraid because my
eight-year-old nephew is constantly
asking me are you afraid are you afraid
i don't
want him to see my feelings
they destroyed our city i think by 50
today
so it's awful it's awful what is
happening i am a normal person i'm
afraid but i am getting angrier and
angrier
with every moment with every day and
i am hoping that uh that the world will
stop
will stop putin
somebody will do something to make him
stop this war
it's a disaster it's a world's disaster